[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brands from the
long now foundation and the long now is
usually described as last ten thousand
years in the next 10,000 years
civilizations stories how we refer to it
but it's not the live only long in our
round it's not the longest now around
the woolly mammoth separated off from
Asian elephant other mammoth type
creatures about six million years ago
the passenger pigeons separated off from
our local bird the band-tailed pigeon
about still figuring it out exactly
maybe eighteen million years ago the
passenger pigeons were done in by
civilization about a hundred years ago
the whole analysis were done in partly
by pre civilization about ten to twelve
thousand years ago and if civilization
rises to the occasion and uses the
amazing tools it's developing you might
get these animals back into the long now
they're accustomed to and be around for
another six million years or 18 million
years person who's been in the thick of
that is one of those rare biologists who
is a surpassingly good bench biologist
and a one of those field biologists who
has way more fun than anybody deserves
to have Beth Shapiro
oh goodness never know what to say when
Stuart stands up and says humiliating
things like that um so I'd like to start
off by thanking Stuart and and Ryan
Phelan and revive and restore and of
course the long now foundation Ryan and
Stuart have been friends and mentors of
mine for some time now and I'm really
grateful for all the help and
encouragement that they've given and I
just wanted to start off by thanking
them and it's like to thank you guys for
taking the time to come and listen to me
this evening hopefully I will at least
entertain you if not to surprise you um
if you get really bored we're mad just
walk out that's fine I don't mind
perfectly customs that kind of thing
just kidding all right so today I'm
gonna talk about how to clone a mammoth
and I'll tell you a little bit about how
I got into it but I thought I would I
would start off by introducing you to
the kind of science that we do and what
better way then as Stuart so kindly
points out but to show you what we do
when we're in the field so um one of the
many hats I wear is as a it's called an
emerging Explorer with of National
Geographic I'm not really sure what I'm
emerging from but that's the title and
this is a little bit of stuff that we
shot in the field a few years ago that
we put together for the World Science
Festival which is in was in New York
City a few years ago so just to start
off a little short video clip
this is really cool we've just found you
can see is one two three four pieces of
vomit come here this is part of the
vertebra so you can see how businesses
and the neat thing about this is that
these are the small pieces which means
that the stuff is washed down the street
see these pieces are actually still
frozen in the permafrost we can't get
them out at all which means are gonna be
really well preserved just heard that
big splash of water back there that
means another hole broken through here
comes the water we better get out of
here
that's a little bit silly but in my own
defense that water is really gross okay
so that was up near Dawson City in
Canada's Yukon Territory where there's a
lot of active gold mining going on what
that what that is right there is during
the spring snowmelt they collect the
melting water in these big holding ponds
and then they pump it up using these
high-pressure water hoses and wash down
the permafrost the frozen dirt and they
wash it down for a little bit and then
they wait and the frozen bits thaw for
the next couple of inches and they wash
it down a little bit more and all this
time they're getting rid of these you
know hundreds of thousands of years of
decaying plants and animal matter it's
disgusting you don't want that on top of
yourself right gross so the miners are
actually trying to get rid of all the
permafrost because the gold is actually
in the gravels beneath but as they're
doing that tons and tons of bones come
out bones from ice age animals that we
can collect and take back to the lab so
I'm a biologist a molecular biologist or
evolutionary biologist or molecular
paleontologist whatever you want to call
it I make up something new pretty much
every time I say it I'm actually
interested in climate change and how
species and communities are affected by
climate change so when we see things or
hear stories about climate change often
what we actually see are pictures like
this one where we hear about changes in
weather patterns that are causing you
know Lakes to disappear rivers to dry up
California that kind of thing right
increases and changes in storm patterns
and of course species that are pushed to
the brink of extinction and if we read
about this in the popular press often
what we're told is that everything is
going terribly horribly wrong right you
know and what are we gonna do about it
well that's exactly what we try to do as
biologists what we want to know is how
our species and communities and
ecosystems going to respond to the
climate change that's happening now and
that's predicted for the next several
decades or centuries so if you follow
the climate change literature at all
you've probably seen a plot that looks
like this
this is very famously called a hockey
stick plot you see right here this looks
a little bit like a hockey stick where
we have the tall end of the stick and
then curving up here what this plot
actually is is the line that goes across
is the average global temperature around
1960 and then what we see are changes in
global temperature around the last
thousand years and within the last
couple hundred years global temperatures
have increased quite considerably about
a degree and a half Celsius over just a
couple hundred years and of course this
plot can be extended into the future
where we can see kind of crazy estimates
of how quickly the temperature's going
to rise this however is not the first
time in recent history where the world
has warmed up pretty quickly if we
extend this plot backward in time now to
50,000 years ago and it ends just where
this plot begins around a thousand years
we see that around 20,000 years ago
right here there was a very rapid
increase in global temperatures in fact
this increase is eight degrees not a
degree and a half and this second half
of the increase this by the way is the
peak of the last ice age and this right
here is the transition into the warm
Holocene interval that we have right now
but we've collected data from the Arctic
where we work that suggests that this
last increase might have happened over
as few years as a couple of decades or
about a century so this is a past period
of incredibly rapid climate change that
is as destructive and as consequential
for things that are alive as whatever is
predicted for the future so what we do
is we go back in time and study
communities over this time interval and
ask how did species and communities and
ecosystems respond to this past period
of very rapid climate change the goal
then would be to try to make better
decisions about what to do with the
limited resources and energy that we
have to deal with climate change that's
projected for the future so the field I
work in is called ancient DNA pretty
self-explanatory it means very old DNA
not grandma's DNA but you know pretty
old DNA we can go back a lot further
than a couple hundred years the oldest
DNA we've been able to extract from
something as from a horse bone that we
know is around 700 thousand years old
that's pretty old right we work mostly
in a place called Beringia Beringia
spans from kind of the western part of
canada here all the way across this is
the Bering Strait into this the part of
the world that Sarah Palin can see from
her backyard right so you see that
there's this kind of light color here
that's because the sea isn't as deep
there and during ice ages when a lot of
the Earth's water was taken up into
making big glaciers that sat on top of
the continents this was actually exposed
it wasn't under water it was a very rich
grassland and this area right here was a
land bridge that connected North America
and Asia and allowed lots of species to
go back and forth horses and camels went
in this direction
bison other species including our own
went in this direction and there was
exchanged between these two continents
today Beringia looks a lot like this I'm
actually in this helicopter looking down
taking the picture here this is in the
timer' Peninsula in north-central
Siberia I'll show you a picture of that
fantastic flying machine in just a
moment but during the last ice age it
looked more like this
where you had lots of different species
of herbivores that were grazing
on a very rich grassland and preyed upon
by many different species of carnivores
so we fly out into this fantastic area
here's this lovely machine you see that
it's actually missing some helicopter
windows here in the helicopter that's
actually good just in case you want to
smoke in celebration of taking off I'm
not saying that happened I'm also not
saying it didn't happen it wasn't me
we stay in five-star accommodation this
is um this is a picture of my tent that
I took by backing up and unfocus immense
dust you could see that the depth of
mosquitoes that we deal with when we're
up there yep those are all mosquitoes
and we walk along areas where the
permafrost is thawing so this is back in
Dawson City in the Yukon Territory and
you see that this is them washing down
the permafrost with this high-pressure
water hose and
some people from our group kind of
wandering around picking up the bones
that wash out so in one day of
collecting around Dawson City we'll
often collect somewhere between 5 and 20
bags that bags that look like this this
is mostly bison bones and horse bones
there's also mammoths and caribou
every now and then we get really lucky
and we get a lion or a wolf or a big
bear some sort of carnivore that was
there pretty exciting we take a little
chunk out of each of the bones and take
it back to the lab and extract DNA and
what we do is we then correlate the
amount of genetic diversity we see in
these populations at any one time point
with how big the population was lots of
diversity or increasing diversity means
the population is growing very little
diversity means the population is
shrinking and we've learned quite a lot
in the last couple of decades doing this
kind of work we've learned for example
that bison and horses and mammoths
peaked in population size somewhere
around 40 to 35 thousand years ago and
this is really interesting because two
of the main the two main hypotheses
about what killed off things like
mammoths and mastodons around eight to
ten thousand years ago are they didn't
really like the ice age the peak of the
last ice age that was about twenty to
twenty-five thousand years ago or that
humans killed them and in North America
there are at large numbers of humans
until after about fourteen thousand
years ago so that these species started
to decline toward extinction well before
more than twenty thousand years before
humans arrived for example kind of puts
us off the hook for the initial part of
that decline not quite willing to let us
off the hook for the ultimate extinction
but you know we'll get there eventually
we've also seen the carnivore population
like bears expand in response to growing
populations of herbivores and move
across space really rapidly establishing
lots of new populations and we've
started to figure out why some species
like caribou do so well they don't like
to live near humans that's a hint and
other species like cave Lions have done
particularly poorly and we often publish
this work and pretty high-profile
journals we get a lot of interest from
the popular press and the scientific
press and you know my mom and stuff like
that and I'm always really excited to
talk about our work and to you know to
spread some of the knowledge that we've
learned about what we can do now to try
to protect species in the present day
from potentially going extinct and yet
they only ever really asked me one
question so the field the field that
this has become is called de-extinction
I'm not sure where that name came from
and I don't really like it but we're
kind of stuck with it I don't like it
cuz it's really hard to conjugate you
know what do you say your D extinct ting
something that's just terrible
right of course we're all familiar with
D extinction because we were there when
we did it last time right and we know
that it went exceedingly well you know
nothing went wrong at all life didn't
find a way so the way this worked of
course was that the scientists at
Jurassic Park were able to recover
dinosaur DNA from mosquitoes entombed in
amber well bad news there is no DNA
mosquito or dinosaur or otherwise in
amber in fact scientists at University
College London and the Natural History
Museum in London were able to show that
even in copal which is a precursor to
amber that's only a couple of decades
old
there is no DNA it's too hot an
environment in too porous an environment
in DNA doesn't survive of course there
are lots of dinosaur bones out there
surely we could look in those well
dinosaur bones are actually rocks right
that's what it means to be fossilized to
everything that's in there that was
biological is now a rock and we can't
get DNA's from from rocks which means we
we can't clone dinosaurs sorry
of course mammoth bones are not rocks
and we know that there are very many
incredibly well-preserved mammoths main
threat mammoths remains including some
fantastic mummies that have been found
especially recently melting out of the
Siberian permafrost so can we bring back
a mammoth and that's what I'm gonna tell
you about in the next 30 minutes or so
how to clone a mammoth so the first plan
that people generally think of when
we're gonna think about bringing back a
mammoth is cloning so plan a let's clone
a mammoth cloning in fact is a very
specific scientific process and the
science words for it or somatic cell
nuclear transfer somatic cell nuclear
transfer so with our bodies we basically
have two types of cells sperm and eggs
those are germline cells or germ cells
and everything else
those are somatic cells hair cells cheek
cells heart cells skin cells whatever
those are all somatic cells so the key
to somatic cell nuclear transfer is to
convince a cell that isn't a germline
cell so normally what would happen is a
sperm and an egg meet create a zygote
that thing can then divide and become
every part of an animal every single
part somatic cells are pretty stuck in
what they are a skin cell can't suddenly
decide to be a heart cell or a liver
cell and a liver cell can't suddenly
decide to be a skin cell so the trick
here is to take one of those cells that
already knows what it's supposed to be
has all the instructions for being a
specific type of cell and trick it into
reverting into a cell that can then
become every other type of cell in an
organism so the most famous example of
somatic cell nuclear transfer was the
experiment done by the Roslin Institute
in Edinburgh in the mid-1990s that
brought us Dolly the sheep
remember Dolly the sheep so what
happened here was Dolly
oh sorry dolly is the offspring some
sheep they took a who knows what Dolly's
clone was actually called I have no idea
there's something it seems like
something we should know I'm sure
somebody knows just not me anyway they
took a mammary cell so a cell that was
pretty
pretty sure knew what it was gonna be it
was gonna be a mammary cell and they
took a couple of cells in and starved
them of nutrients pretty much just
stressed them out put him in a dish in a
lab stressed him out at the same time
they harvested some egg cells from a
different breed of you and they sucked
the nucleus the genetic material out of
that cells and now they had an empty egg
cell and this starved cell over here and
they put them next to each other and zap
them with a bit of electricity in the
membrane bursts and the nuclear material
from that starved somatic cell dumps
into the egg cell right and then you zap
him again and the proteins in that egg
cell actually caused that mannery cell
to forget all of the instructions for
being a mammary cell and reset into one
of those early forms of cells that could
then go on to become every type of cell
in an organism then that egg cell
develops into a embryo which is
implanted in a surrogate which is yet
another breed of sheep and eventually
Dolly is born and Dolly is a genetic
clone of the donor you and not of the
donor of the egg cell or of the
surrogate mother so how would this work
with the mammoths well we go out into
the field and we find an incredibly
well-preserved mammoths and then we take
out some of the cells and we stress them
out in a dish in a lab and then we
insert them into an egg cell some
magical thing happens right it resets
that cell and then we stick it inside a
mom elephant and it grows out to be a
baby elephant and we release it into the
environment
pretty straightforward well we do find a
lot of incredibly well-preserved remains
in the Arctic this is a horse jaw here
that is from the Klondike near Dawson
City and that horse job is probably
somewhere around 40 to 50,000 years old
but it looks like it just could have
been deposited a little while ago we
find again these incredibly
well-preserved bones there are lots of
mummies that we find all the time and a
few summers ago you might have seen on
the news this team that found this
really well-preserved frozen mammoth
mummy melting out of the permafrost in
the new Siberian islands this is the one
that was supposedly associated with
liquid substance liquid red substance
that looked like blood I don't think
it's been proven that it was blood and I
have my doubts but you know these are
incredibly well preserved and yet in all
of these remains there will never be an
intact cell and that's because as soon
as an organism dies the DNA begins to
decay the Sun is a terrible source of UV
radiation we know that we walk outside
we want to cover in sunscreens that it
doesn't actually destroy make nicks and
break our DNA well we have enzymes in
our bodies that can go along and fix
those things but those all require
energy and once we're dead we have no
more energy
there are also enzymes from the bacteria
that are in our own guts if you're a
mummy and you start to decay that gut
bursts in the yet and those bacteria go
everywhere and start chewing up the DNA
sequences in the cells a bone that gets
buried in the ground is going to be
attacked by soil microbes and fungi and
all sorts of things that will chew up
the DNA in the cells freezing and
thawing is terrible oxygen water all of
these things are terrible for DNA
survival and as soon as an organism dies
the DNA begins to decay there are no
living cells which means we cannot clone
a mammoth
thank you for coming of course there is
another way right so a few weeks ago a
team of scientists an international team
led by a group out of the Natural
History Museum in Sweden Stockholm
published a paper in which they've
reported that they had sequenced the
complete genomes of two mammoths one
from wrangle island that was around
3,500 years old and another from Siberia
that was about 440 thousand years old so
now we have these sequences of A's C's
GS and T's the letter that makes up our
DNA that makes for the code for the
genes that make the proteins that make
us look anak the way we do we have all
of this all four billion of them for a
mammoth so surely we could just go into
the lab and synthesize long strands of a
C's GS and T's get them into a
chromosome and then put those
chromosomes into the cell right and then
put that cell into the other cell and
then the whole thing with the yeah so
first let's talk about the word complete
when we use that to describe a genome
sequence right so there aren't really
any complete genome sequences for
vertebrate species out there including
humans right now to be fair we do know
most of the sequence of the human genome
and we definitely know all the parts or
most the parts that have genes in them
the part that make proteins that make us
look to knock the way we do but there
are parts of the human genome especially
those that are close to the center and
of chromosomes and near the ends of the
chromosomes that are actually made up of
really tightly condensed repeat regions
that there's no existing sequencing
technology that we can read through
which means that we can't actually start
from one end of the chromosome and build
a long sequence of a C's GS and T's
that's exactly the right sequence for
even a human chromosome and it's a lot
harder for something that's been extinct
for a long time and there are two main
reasons that why building or understand
the complete genome sequence of
something that's no longer alive is very
hard
first just goes back to one of what I
was saying earlier about the DNA being
degraded the sequences that we recover
from a mammoth bone are actually very
short and they have lots of chemical
damage that's really characteristic of
ancient DNA so if you imagine that a
long of a modern sequence if you were to
get it out of a living animal was like a
big long party streamer ancient DNA when
we get it out of a mammoth bone is more
like confetti but I couldn't actually
find a picture of confetti the day after
the parade in the gutter where it was
raining and there were like elephants in
the parade and passenger pigeons flying
overhead so this is the closest enough
close enough to what it really looks
like but it's actually not that good
okay the second reason is that the
samples themselves if we extract DNA
from a mammoth bone it's not just
mammoth DNA that we can get out of them
so if I were to extract DNA from a piece
of my own hair or from a swab from the
inside of my cheek what I would get
would be something like this so I
extract DNA and then sequence everything
I get in that extract pretty much all of
what I would get out of there would be
my own DNA that's because I'm alive
pretty good shape not contaminated as
far as I know if I were to extract DNA
from a mammoth bone and we have done
this experiment and then sequence
everything I get out of that extract so
this is the plot a similar plot to this
from the first time that we did this
which was about a decade ago now we got
a sample where about half about half of
the DNA that we recovered from that DNA
extracted from a mammoth bone was
actually mammoth DNA the rest of it was
environmental DNA and microbial DNA from
the soil there was a lot that we didn't
know what it was it was probably also
soil microbial DNA but because there's
so much diversity of DNA in the soil
there's just not a lot that we could
compare it to so we get a bit confused
along the way so about about half and we
were we were pretty bummed you know we
thought this was this was a bad sign
this meant we were never really going to
be able to sequence a complete mammoth
genome but as ecce later we actually now
know that this was an incredibly
well preserved specimen and in fact most
of the bones that we extract DNA from
contain much less and dodging asur host
DNA than that many you might be familiar
with in neanderthal genome sequencing
project the first bones that that team
used to extract Neanderthal DNA there
were several bones and those bones all
had less than 1% in the and earth all
DNA in it 99% of that stuff was just
thrown away because it was just other
stuff mostly soil bacteria that had
gotten into those bones after they were
buried so instead of just having this
imagine we just get all of our dirty
gross confetti and what we really want
are just the purple pieces right so it's
actually quite hard it's actually not a
really straightforward thing to do so
how do we know how can we even tell
which pieces are purple and which pieces
are not purple how do we know how to
come up with the mammoth genome that we
have well fortunately we live in a time
where we do have lots of good sequences
and if we're interested in sequencing
the mammoth genome we have an elephant
genome that we can use as a scaffold as
a map to use to figure out where those
tiny little broken fragments do and if
we're assembling the neanderthal genome
we have a human genome that we can use
and so we take these short little broken
fragments that we have and then we map
them to the existing genome from
closely-related living species and what
we end up with is a good idea a pretty
good approximation of what these
different sequences would have looked
like these genome sequences of course if
there are parts of the genome where the
thing that we're trying to assemble the
extinct species it's very different from
the thing that we've already assembled
the living species
we're probably gonna miss that we're
probably gonna think that it's just
another bit of soil microbial DNA and
throw it out and if we're really
interested in finding those bits of the
genome where the mammoth is most
different from an elephant one might
think that these places that we can't
map because we don't have the mem the
genome are probably kind of important
another problem is that having a
sequence even if we could string
together long strands of a C's GS and
T's is
not the same thing as having a living
cell so we are getting better at
stringing together these things but we
don't know how to wrap them up in the
correct way to make them turn into
chromosomes and we don't know how to get
those chromosomes into cells so if it's
plan B sequencing and assembling our own
mammoths that we're really gonna use to
bring back the mammoths we're kind of
stuck on step one so guess what but
there is another way or we wouldn't be
here right so the third way and this is
the way that probably is going to be
used if we are going to proceed with
this particular stuff at all would be to
engineer ourselves a mammoth and it's
really a simple process overall kind of
conceptually we think about engineering
a mammoth as a a giant cut and paste job
where really what we're trying to do is
find bits of the genome that are -
elephant like to be a mammoth and chop
those out and then replace them with
parts of the genome that are mammoth
like so we start with this sequence that
we have and we can compare the sequences
of a mammoth and an elephant and we can
identify regions of the genome where
Asian elephants all look one way and
mammoths all look another way and these
two things are different from each other
and then we can take an Asian elephant
cell and we can just cut out those bits
that are Asian elephant specific and
replace them with the bits the same bits
but the mammoth version of those genes
so imagine you had a little machine that
you could program to go into the genome
inside the nucleus of the cell and find
exactly a specific place in the genome
and imagine that you could arm that
little machine with the sequence of DNA
that it would take with it and that DNA
could be the mammoth version of a gene
that it could kind of chop out and
replace in turns out we have that
machine and it's not actually a
synthetic thing it's not something
that's been created by people in fact
it's an enzyme protein complex that
we've stolen hijacked a bit from
bacteria and archaea that those
organisms use to protect themselves from
invading pathogens and that machine is
called CRISPR CRISPR Castine it's been
in the news a lot recently because it's
incredibly powerful
therefore a little bit controversial but
it can potentially do so here's our
little machine this is the CRISPR here's
our elephant DNA and here's the bit that
we want to change this little piece
right here is the part of that machine
that can go in and recognize and grab a
hold of a specific part of that elephant
genome and then we send in with that
machine a little package that is the
elephant version of a particular gene
that we want to replace our little
machine the CRISPR molecule 5 is that
part of the genome and it cuts the DNA
strand in half now cells don't like to
be cut in half genomes don't like to be
cut in half to sell and so they have a
couple of different mechanisms that have
evolved over time to fix when you get
damaged inside a cell like this the idea
then would be to harness the cell's own
repair machinery to fix this double
strand break but at the same time stick
in that mammoth version of the F
whatever it was that's been cut out
right and then you end up with an
elephant that is just a little bit
mammoth like so what do we change if we
want to go in there well we know that
mammoths and the Asian elephants
diverged somewhere around six million
years ago and that means that they're
gonna have around 99% similar genomes to
start off with so there's only gonna be
somewhere between a million and a
million and a half places where Asian
elephants and mammoths are actually
different from each other now I'm not
saying we would have to make all of
these changes but the first thing we
might want to do is figure out which
genes which things that code for
proteins that actually change the way an
organism looks or acts we might want to
change between a mammoth and an elephant
well about five years ago a group in
Manitoba Kevin Campbell's lab figured
out that there is a gene hemoglobin gene
to protein and red blood cells which is
responsible for carrying oxygen around
the body that the hemoglobin of wooly
mammoths was different from that of
Asian elephants by only three changes
three changes that's pretty easy to make
right and then to see to figure out what
these three changes actually did they
made these cells these hemoglobin cells
in a dish
and they measured what the difference
was between the mammoth version of
hemoglobin and the elephant version of
hemoglobin and it turns out that the
mammoth version of hemoglobin is much
better at carrying oxygen around the
body at low temperatures so this is
pretty clearly something that we might
want to change if what we're interested
in doing is baking an elephant that's
able to live like a mammoth so what else
well there's lots of possibilities and
big long list and there's actually a
team at Harvard at the Wyss Institute
that's big led by George Church and
there's other crew here who fondly call
themselves the mammoth revivalists I
like that term it's pretty cool and they
have so far changed 14 genes mostly
thinking about genes that are involved
in thermal regulation and being able to
create a a warm-blooded animal
tropically adapted elephant that can
live in cooler places like a mammoth
could and they have attempted 14 changes
and successfully made 14 changes and
have created something that is
approximately atalia amount mammoth in a
dish in the lab all right this is cells
growing in a lab which is a big
difference from having an actual living
breathing mammoth but it's a really
fantastic and exciting start so it turns
out that here we do have the genome
sequence of a mammoth so we can check
that one off the list and we also have
this kind of technology that we can use
to take an elephant genome sequence and
turn it into a mammoth genome sequence
and that's that CRISPR technology and
then what we have is an elephant cell a
living elephant cell growing in a dish
in the lab which means we can use
somatic cell nuclear transfer and clone
an elephant and then we have to put it
in a female and grow it up to being a
little baby and release it into the
woods well we call this part of
de-extinction which i'm just now getting
to phase 2 so when we hear about
de-extinction or cloning mammoths or
whatever in the popular press often this
part this phase 2 is kind of glossed
over
the idea being that since we can
sequence these things and we can change
and edit genomes in a Cell that means
that we're next to just really close to
having a mammoth born tomorrow
right well it turns out we're really far
from this because this is something that
we can't do for Elephants we don't know
how to do this for Elephants and we
really haven't thought about what we're
gonna do with them right so this is
phase two is potentially even more
difficult than phase one husband and
it's gonna vary depending on what
species were talking about but there are
considerable challenges the first step
of course would be to find an
appropriate surrogate mom
so for species that are recently extinct
or have very closely related living
relatives this step might be doable
right maybe Asian elephants would be a
good surrogate host for a mammoth and
the bucardo project this ibex that used
to live in the Pyrenees there are very
closely related other ibex --is that
might be useful surrogate hosts but as
the evolutionary distance between the
thing that you're trying to bring back
and the closest living species increases
how feasible will it be to find an
appropriate surrogate hosts in many
cases there might actually be physical
challenges associated with this think
about size differences between extinct
species and living species this is
probably not a problem for mammoths we
know that the the woolly mammoth that
lived in the Late Pleistocene was
approximately the same size as Asian
elephants so a size difference might not
be a huge problem here however there are
other species that have been suggested
as candidate species 4d extinction where
size differences are probably a pretty
big problem this guy right here is a
Steller's sea cow and that's the foot
for scale this is a big big animal used
to live along the coast of California up
across the Aleutian Islands to the
commanders and when extinct couple
hundred years ago because one of them
could feed a crew of 30 men for a couple
of weeks these were big big animals the
closest living relative of Steller's sea
cow is a dugong right and guys know what
a do gong is pretty normal
well it's still a big animal but nothing
like this crazy thing right here if you
think about it
if we were to assume that the size ratio
between a newborn calf and the mom is
pretty similar in the stellar sea cow
and it's closely related dugongs and
manatees then a newborn Steller's sea
cow would be bigger than its mom
probably not a good idea really gross
actually
we're also increasingly learning about
how how the environments in which we
live and to which we are exposed affect
the way we end up looking and acting we
are much more than the sum of the a C's
GS and T's that make up our genome
sequences and in fact are a product of
our gene and our environment if we were
only a product of our DNA sequences than
identical twins would be identical and
they would remain identical throughout
their lives and yet many of us know
identical twins who are in their old age
by the time they're in their 70s and 80s
they often don't even look like they're
related anymore
and that's because of all the different
environments and diets and stresses that
they've experienced in their lives and
these environmental conditions begin in
development so you're talking about an
animal that's already 99% identical
genetically to the surrogate mom who's
going to be exposed to that surrogate
moms diet and hormones to the stresses
of that surrogate mom during pregnancy
it's going to be born to a different
species elephants we know eat the dung
of their moms in order to establish the
community of microbes that live in their
gut so on this particular newborn nearly
identical genetic elephants would be
exposed to this surrogate host mom's gut
community as well and we're starting to
understand how important microbial
communities are in our own behavior and
appearance there's no reason to suspect
it wouldn't be the same for something
like an elephant or a mammoth
they'll be raised with with elephants
societies and consume whatever diet
elephants consume in captivity who knows
what they're fed in captivity in
different places and all of these things
are going to affect the way these
animals
look and act and speaking of captivity
there are with every species that's a
candidate for D extinction ethical
considerations at every step along the
way not just technical challenges that
we'll address but also ethical
challenges and with elephants in
particular we do not know right now how
to meet the psychological and physical
needs of elephants in captivity
elephants often fail to breed in captive
environments if they do they sometimes
injure or even kill their young until
we've figured out how to meet whatever
needs these animals have in captivity
they shouldn't be in captivity at all
much less being used in this kind of
crazy science crazy experiment to bring
mammoths back and of course it would be
silly of me
not to point out acknowledged notice
that the world has changed a lot since
many of these species that are
candidates for D extinction went extinct
and for many species this here this here
is this native range of the passenger
pigeon there isn't really a place to put
them if we were to bring them back so
the extinction can we do it not yet but
the technology is changing really
quickly and I have little doubt that
there will be a time in the future where
we can say at least for some species
that it will be possible to bring them
back but I think a really important
question to ask ourselves is whether we
should and as someone who's written a
book on this subject clearly I have a
very clear and sincere and honest and
open opinion about this and I do I have
no idea
I think that it actually depends on what
species you're thinking about and how
how much you've thought about the
different aspects of what's what's going
on there are a lot of different species
that are candidates for D extinction
projects they're the heath hen and the
passenger pigeon which is a project
working with revive and restore and ben
novack from my lab the gastric brooding
frog this guy was amazing do you see
that it actually swallows its babies and
then throws them up after they're fully
developed what an awesome way to stop
them from from from being eaten by
predators the Oryx the the ancestor of
domestic cattle being worked on by some
folks in the Netherlands this is the
bucardo this really beautiful ibex
that's only recently extinct
there's the Steller's sea cow again of
course mammoth thylacine there are lots
of different species that have been
proposed but I think for each of these
what the people who've been working on
them and what and what kind of the
people who are thinking about these
projects have been doing and maybe not
so much some of the more extremely
excited members of the the popular press
haven't been doing is stepping back and
asking themselves why now we're thinking
about why but thinking about why is
probably more important initially than
thinking about how why do we want to
bring these animals back and to finish
I'm gonna return to the mammoth for a
moment because I actually think there
are some compelling reasons why we might
consider bringing a mammoth back or at
least creating an elephants I can live
in places where a mammoth once lived and
we're going to step over the fact that
technically it's not possible and
ethically it's a terrible idea and just
move on to why we might want to be
thinking about this stuff in the first
place so the first reason is ecological
there is a place in northeastern Siberia
called Pleistocene Park this is a big
grew accustomed and that a Russian
scientist Sergei Zhdanov has started
purchasing since the mid 1990s near his
home in char ski and he's preparing this
land for the return of the Ice Age
animals
like mammoths and woolly rhinos and
things like that and so far he has bison
that he imported from Canada some horses
and also about five different species of
deer and he's been studying these
animals in the affect of these animals
on the landscape that he has there and
he's been doing what are called
exclosure experiments here and what he's
done is he's has some parts of
Pleistocene Park where these animals
aren't allowed to graze and other parts
where they are so on one side of this
fence this side over here he does not
have grazing herbivores and what you see
is that there's pretty much only one
species of grass there's it's not very
productive it really can't support a
large population of herbivores and on
the other side of this fence you can't
see it very well but there's lots of
little patches of green grass and in
fact there are many different species of
grass this is a very rich community you
note there's a lot of dirt there too
what's important here is that this is
very early spring it's after the first
snowmelt but before the grass has had a
chance to regenerate what this means is
that these little Tufts of green grass
here have actually are actually still
there despite that it's just been a very
harsh Siberian winter that means that
this is incredibly rich land and what
Sergei has shown is that just just
having these animals on the landscape
just over the course of a couple years
has turned this relatively poorly
productive tundra into a rich grassland
that's actually capable of supporting
these herbivores in a sense these
animals have created and maintain their
own environment just by walking along
the dirt by turning up that soil by
recycling nutrients and distributing
seeds and not only is there sufficient
land for these animals to be able to
live throughout the winter but he's seen
other species like Saiga antelope that
are relatively rare and endangered given
that there's not very much for them to
eat come and visit the park because it
is such a rich grassland and he
maintains that creating these animals
and having them on this landscape can
put that Siberians hunter that rich land
that supported all those animals back on
that landscape providing habitat for
populations that are alive today but in
danger of extinction because their
habitat is declining the second reason
is more sentimental now few of us can
imagine a world without elephants but
Asian elephants are endangered they're
on the endangered species list their
habitat is declining as populations grow
and we're having trouble protecting them
from poaching what if we could use this
technology not to bring mammoths back
since we can't we're never gonna create
something that's a hundred percent
identical to a species that is no longer
alive but what if we could use this
technology instead to save elephants
what if we could take an elephant and
insert a few genes here and there to
allow it to live in temperate North
America or Europe or somewhere like Asia
perhaps then we could hold on to
elephants
long enough to find a way to protect
their habitat and environment so that
they can be re-established as healthy
populations not on the endangered
species list but why stop there
this technology is incredibly powerful
the ability to learn a sequence of DNA
and inject it into another species
that's still alive today we are facing a
crisis an extinction crisis a loss of
diversity crisis this technology is kind
of scary and it's kind of unknown but
it's also clear that what we've been
doing so far is not enough species
continue to go extinct habitat continues
to decline I would argue that now's the
time to change now's the time to take
advantage of these technologies that are
potentially powerful new weapons in our
Arsenal against extinction and use them
use them in our fight against the
declining diversity that we know is
going on in the world today and I'd like
to highlight one project that I know is
one of the keystone projects of revive
and restore that's just an idea of how
we might be able to use this tech
nology not to bring something extinct
back to life but to save things that are
alive today and that's the black-footed
ferrets black footed ferrets nearly went
extinct a couple decades ago because of
a hunting and extermination program
today there are black footed ferrets but
they're genetically almost identical to
each other they've been through a very
recent population bottleneck and now
there's a disease that's killing them
what if we could use this technology and
go back in time and sequence genomes of
black footed ferrets that were sampled
prior to the population bottleneck or
that are in museum collections from
hundreds thousands even tens of
thousands of years ago and sample the
parts of the genome that provide
increased immunity diversity at the MHC
complex for example in this particular
animal and then you could take that bit
of DNA and inject it a genetic booster
shot if you will into black footed
ferrets that are still alive today
potentially you'd be able to give these
animals this living endangered
population a fighting chance against the
disease that's killing them this
I think this capacity to save ecosystems
and species today that are in danger of
extinction is I think the most powerful
application of this technology now I'd
like to end there thank you very much
[Applause]
we run around freezing I can't believe
you'd say that after all that Arctic
frost city you showed us least there's
no mosquitoes one thing that might be
interesting to this group is the early
years of ancient DNA research when
people started you know drilling into
these various things and saying while
we're finding genes there are millions
of years old and stuff like that see a
little bit about that period and what
happened then so some of the first
publications that came out in ancient
DNA where we're about DNA extracted from
things like dinosaur bones and
mosquitoes preserved in amber and it
turns out that the technology that we
use to be able to extract these tiny
little broken pieces of DNA is really
powerful and in fact it's incredibly
good at picking up tiny little broken
pieces of DNA that are just floating in
the air and a lot of what what was
initially sequenced and then published
as supposedly dinosaur DNA or mosquito
DNA really was just contamination stuff
that was sequenced from the site in fact
I talked a little bit about the the
group that worked at the Museum in
London on the copal and amber DNA so
they actually went into the bat
collection at the Museum and they picked
a whole bunch of pieces of amber and
also copal more recent pieces of copal
some that had insects in them and some
that didn't have insects in them and
then they extracted DNA from these guys
and tried to amplify some conserved bits
of insect DNA and they did get insect
DNA but there was no correlation between
getting insect DNA from amber or copal
and they're actually being insects in
the amber or cobalt you book you talk
about and you're getting this a little
bit at the end of the concept of
ecological resurrection and there's you
know there's been concepts like
rewilding which came along
about 10-15 years ago and then was that
was really controversial alliance in my
backyard and I want that and then the
whole ecological replacement notion if
you can place one kind of land tortoise
with another land tortoise and the land
doesn't care and nobody cares is that
were this all fits in or what's your
sense of that yeah I think it is except
you know it allows us to happen a little
bit more speedily the the the team in
the Netherlands that's interested in
bringing back the ORAC are using a
process not a type of not one of those
steps that I suggested but it's
something called back breeding the idea
being that you you look at traits in
individuals that that are similar to
what you're trying to bring back and
then you breed those individuals
together and hope that the right traits
come out this is kind of what the
rewilding the movement wants to do so
you have to rely on the slow Nass
slowness of natural selection and
evolution to select for traits or allow
species to adapt to whatever new
environment they're going to be in what
we're contending is that that happens
but you also use genetic modification
and genome engineering just to speed up
that process a little bit when things
have very long generation times or are
or slow or a very not particularly fit
for an environment where you might want
to put them then maybe we do need to
give them this a little bit of a push
that we can do with changing their DNA
sequences okay so people get worked up
about that and they think that's an
ethical issue do you think that's an
ethical issue
changing DNA sequences well it's just
faster it's a it's a faster way of doing
what we've been doing for the last
thirty thousand years since we first
domesticated gray wolves and tried to
make dogs no we we are a manipulating
nature by trying to create some
phenotype that we want rather than what
the natural way would be I guess the
question is one of the sort of norms I
think they'll be emerging around this
whole practice is the idea of in
conservation at least sort of the
minimal intervention what does the
minimal intervention you can make to get
the outcome that you want ecologically
well conservation there are really two
main schools of thought about what to do
and the one is is preservationist so is
the idea that we can just buy up large
swathe of lands and allow nature space
to recover on its own bits of land that
we can stay out of and the other way of
thinking about is it's kind of like
gardening so instead of just buying up
land we're actually then gonna go in and
manipulate it in some way and while I'd
like to say that the preservationist way
is the way to go cuz it's the most
natural it's very clear that that's also
not working it's not fast enough our
environment is changing too quickly
species can't keep up I think we have to
go in there and get our hands dirty
otherwise it's going to be too late it's
too slow we'll take that another layer
in so the Europeans still like GMOs and
so that's why the guys who are trying to
make it back the European or oxygen
don't worry no GMOs here we're just
doing back reading and you're saying
that's slow and kind of random and in
fact if you go in and and not just with
marker genes that look at the genes
they're there but look at I would like
this gene that gives the forward horns
of the aurochs from this strange animal
over here and get the things that make
horns you can figure out those treat all
those the genes to make those phenotypic
traits happen and move it in there and
not screw around and wait too long now
on the one hand that you're pians this
decade but probably not next it okay
thanks it feels like a big violation of
something but it also sounds that you're
saying that's actually a lot cleaner and
simpler in some respects because you
know what you're doing you're not just
messing around right sure so if you're
if you're just breeding traits together
you might get a particular trait that
you want but you don't know if you've
gotten it in the same way that evolution
got it in the first place whereas if you
actually going in and making a specific
change you know that you're creating the
thing that used to exist or the thing
that actually causes this particular
trade to emerge it's a lot more
complicated than that genes don't
operate in a vacuum they operate within
the context of the entire genome so in
there are will always be unintended
consequences for any of this but no more
so with genetic modification and there
is with standard breeding well I've got
is that there's sort of an endless
series of arguments and and I guess
discussions that will go on of purists
versus pragmatists and you know who's
the purist and who's the pragmatist each
one of these things sort of flips back
and forth yeah here's a here's a
pragmatic question from Kevin Kelly can
you use Plan C technology so if you're
gonna try to make a ban tailed pigeon
have enough passenger pigeon traits that
it can behave like a passenger pigeon
look like a passenger pigeon and poop on
them firstly watch cars like opinion
time it happens there will be cars
anymore depends how quickly Ben works
you could do that that's pretty
interesting but the question is is that
really quote enough and so Kevin's
question is could use Plan C technology
to engineer living subspecies to become
living so species become basically
another living subspecies in other words
the proof of this pudding really would
be to turn the band-tailed pigeon into a
mourning dove right right if it's with
mourning doves and the Oh babes like a
mourning dove and all of that yeah
should we do that first first I don't
know about first I don't know you know
you could use this technology to do lots
of things I mean this is part of the
reason why it's so controversial and a
few weeks ago there was a Chinese group
that published the the paper Soudan that
they had actually used the same
technology to edit human embryos and has
caused quite a big stir and there are
these pushes now from a lot of the
scientists who've been involved to not
use this technology until we understand
more about the implications of it but it
is incredibly powerful let's say you had
a whole bunch of sequences from all the
different birds that exist let's say you
had 50 bird genomes and you also knew
the genome sequences of the alligator
crocodile and gharial we know these
things
right now we could computationally biown
dramatically reconstruct the sequence of
the first bird which is a dinosaur right
the other board tell us about the or
bird you are this is 70 million years
ago this bird existed I think more but
yes fifty to a hundred million years
yeah and what are we saying these days
80 million years ago there was a bird
that was before all the neo obvious or
something that all right
yeah the ancestor of all living birds
okay we're also dinosaurs birds are
dinosaurs so you can infer the genome of
this bird that hasn't been around and
all of that time right and then we could
take a bird whose genome sequence we
know like a chicken or a pigeon and we
could swap out all of the sequences that
we wanted to swap out and that
particular bird and come step back
through evolutionary time a little bit
at the time and ask interesting
questions about how different traits of
Alton Birds or how many times different
traits evolved in Birds this is an
incredibly powerful technology it's not
so powerful and that we can't do it at
all
right now because we can't clone birds
but the ideas are powerful okay so it
sounds like this is well underway right
so you can recreate the genome you hope
of potentially livable bird who hasn't
been around for 80 million years and
convert a living bird into that bird
there's gonna be an issue of habitat and
food how big it is how you're gonna
raise it there's all sorts of issues to
to be addressed
do we have a guess how big the er bird
was the guess I don't I don't think
there's any way to guess and birds
themselves vary considerably in size if
you think about like the the MOA the
extinct New Zealand bird that was you
know twice as tall as me it's a tiny
little hummingbirds there's a lot of
variation within birds and there's no
and there we know there was a lot of
variation in dinosaurs so I don't think
there's really a good way to guess how
big it would be what I love about the er
bird
like this it makes you actually fastened
to the bridge and look so so normal and
easy non-controversial and of course you
would do that see a little bit about the
difference between cloning a mammal
right and the impossibility of cloning a
bird right those are very big
generalization categories but for any
species that's been suggested as a
candidate for the extinction there are
different technical ethical and
ecological barriers or considerations
things to think about the biggest
concern with Birds is that you know that
what we've been talking about with
mammals you edit a genome and you end up
with a living cell that you can then
clone using somatic cell nuclear
transfer which is something that we can
do it doesn't work particularly
efficiently still but it is something
that we can do and people have cloned
rabbits and dogs and cats and all sorts
of things birds
we can't clone right we can't have we
don't have access to the egg cell at the
right stage where it's primed to develop
into a living bird but not fertilized
yet we can't actually get the cell at
that it doesn't implant I guess it's
moving down the oviduct right right it
come tumbles down and although you know
when you when you crack an egg you see
that the white is around it and there's
the thick layer that connects it to the
holes of the egg those are all deposited
in about 24 hours between fertilization
in a chicken and when that egg is laid
and once that egg is laid the the embryo
is actually pretty significantly along
the way toward development definitely to
the point where you could not remove it
and then insert another embryo in its
place without causing significant damage
yeah well there are other technologies
that are being developed to to work with
birds and and they're really interesting
and again not near the state where we
could actually do them yet but the idea
would be that when that in a chicken
when the egg is laid the cells that are
gonna go on to become sperm or eggs are
not in the gonads yet because the gonads
don't exist but instead are kind of
migrating around the outside of that
embryo and at that point you could
inject stick a needle in there and suck
out a few of those cells and
can put them in a dish in the lab and
they don't replicate at that point but
they can live in that dish in the lab
for a few days in some species of bird
and at that point you can edit them plan
see them and change those and then you
would take those cells and inject them
into a different egg that's just been
laid and those edited cells would
migrate around the embryo and establish
themselves in the gonads and then the
bird that was born would be totally
normal but its offspring would have
edited DNA if those offspring were made
using the sperm and egg that had been
edited because this would be effectively
a chicken with passenger pigeon gonads
that lays passenger pigeon eggs it
sounds nuts but there have that's
probably the first time someone has said
to Stuart brand that sounds nuts but
there have been there has been a chicken
that they injected duck primordial germ
cells these pre germ cells and then
those duck primordial germ cells migrate
around and then that chicken was
fertilized with duck sperm and then it
laid eggs that hatched into perfect
ducks with proud chickens not knowing
how to raise them such a stickler for
the details you send it over to the guy
well there's a similar issue of thank
you is that there is a workaround
potentially in process we are in the
thick of finding people the Roslin
Institute in Scotland and here a company
in the Bay Area and there's a guy in
Australia Jim Collins I think it is
who's what's his name Ryan Jim Jim Doran
who has figured out a way to shortcut do
it in vivo basically and instead of in
vitro instead of doing all the editing
out here just basically hypodermic right
into the living embryo and some of the
stuff takes up and then you get to start
to do at least trade analysis
and the birds that are coming out of
this chimeric parent yeah it's a
fast-moving field of stuff that we still
can't do speaking of fast moving one of
the issues with the woolly mammoth and
indeed with mammals but particularly
with the woolly mammoth is the perhaps
not excited Asian mother who doesn't
want our eggs harvested which is what's
involved in cloning usually and there's
a sort of sacrifice of animals to get
the eggs harvested and then you do great
many of those and the implants
immobilization all take and so on we
don't have a lot of Asian elephant
females to spare for that sort of thing
and they don't ovulate very frequently
and they lose not very Qin Li although
we did hear from Dennis Smith the the
reproductive veterinarian we're talking
about we said you know if we can get a
mammoth like embryo to implant in a
about to be pregnant female Asian
elephant it was going to be hard to get
it in there he says it's alright I've
got a 10-foot endoscope he's actually
pretty relaxed about that problem
he has great stories to tell but there's
the issue that so in your book you
mentioned well maybe George talks about
artificial uterus right there's actually
moving in that direction the
technologies now got tissues that have
blood supply which is starting to be the
kind of thing you would want you know an
artificial uterus that might get round
the size issue if you were a decade ago
there was someone from Baltimore who
actually used a mouse to grow elephant
eggs so they implanted or or he
hybridized elephant follicles that were
harvested from her recently killed yeah
okay I guess that was round and it
actually got the mouse to grow on its
back a few miss shapen elephant eggs so
the technology doesn't exist but it
could now these are one of these like
anything else in India extinction or
really conservation biology none of the
technology that comes is for this
purpose right and it's all being
developed with human reproductive health
or human genetic health
than mines we just get to write on the
coattails of this really cool stuff and
potentially apply it to important
questions and all of the money and
interest in the huge labs and all that
kind of stuff things kind of draft in
behind that which is neat and yet it is
also the case that there's interest from
some of the medical people in what we're
doing because ethically for very good
reasons there's a lot of stuff you don't
want to try in humans first but you
might want to try in animals first if
there's good ethical reasons to attempt
it for the animals like you described
right but probably not with elephants
probably initially be attempted with lab
animals like you know mice or other
animals that where we know much more
about their reproductive strategies and
we know how to keep them healthy and
happy in labs because we've been working
on them for a long time you know these
model organisms so called what do you
think about there's the thing that's
been done with mice where you get
basically stem cells that are so
pluripotent or omnipotent you can trim
them in two and two sperm and eggs now
that's been done on mice right I
understand it okay and so that leads to
a possible workaround to get from edited
elephant stem cell line edited into
being partly mammoths take those on the
potent stem cells and get them to be
make in two eggs and or sperm do a
little in vitro fertilization and you
get what should be a pretty good egg
that hasn't involved any harvesting from
female mammoths at all and implants that
implanted in what in a ready female
mammoths or in artificial I'm sorry
ready female yeah the problems with
elephants and I'm curious to hear what
your elephant reproductive biologist
said that one of the as far as I
understand one of the problems is that
they have a they have a hymen
that grows back in between each
pregnancy that actually helps to
maintain the pregnancy it's a long
pregnancy very heavy and
as long as two years and the hymen has a
hole in it but it's only big enough for
a sperm to pass through and certainly
not big enough for a partially developed
hybrid mammoths elephant embryo so has
your elephant reproductive biologist
addressed that with this no it's the
next question for me okay but what I
think you're getting a sense of is that
and Beth is terrific at saying you know
there's an insertable barrier here and
then a few years go by and then there's
and then a passable barrier and then
it's routine that we do that and you
know I hearken back i sort of vaguely
remember when in vitro fertilization for
humans was first being developed and the
early stages of that there were a lot of
failures and scary things yeah and if
you look at the success rate for cloning
just somatic cell nuclear transfer style
including Dolly was one of almost 300
different beginnings 300 eggs cells and
somatic cell nuclear transfers gotten
better but it's still extremely
inefficient being often there are
hundreds of cells that are taken that
are tried to reset and hundreds of eggs
that are used and you know it's and
every animal has different challenges
dogs that took a very long time for
anyone to successfully clone a dog
because of some strangeness in their
actual reproductive pattern it was very
hard to time the getting of the eggs
such that work they were able to get
them at the right state to be able to
reset that that somatic cell to turn it
into its kind of cell that would become
every other type of cell in the body
there's only one outfit now that claims
to successfully be able to clone dogs
and they'll clone your dog for you for a
hundred thousand dollars well there how
come they have customers out there for
that you're an evolutionary biologist
and I think one of the questions that
keeps coming up and it's a good one is
you get these animals out in the land
and you go through captive breeding and
there's problems with that you
are doing soft release so they're
starting to you know they're half
captive and they're half in the out in
the world and reintroduction techniques
and protocols have gotten better and
better in the last few decades but now
they're out there and life is tough in
the wild compared to captive breeding we
can't manage in the wild anymore any of
us we've domesticated ourselves too far
to really do hunter-gatherer without a
whole bunch of cultural knowledge we
don't have anymore
so these creatures what happens over
time and example it comes to mind is
something that Ryan and I ran into when
we were in in Tanzania year ago is we
were hearing from some of the guides
that in Africa now there's female
elephants being born without tusks and
they grow to maturity and have baby
elephants without tusks and we thought
well that's a pretty fun story to tell
the eco-tourists and so it makes them
smile now we started checking around
with some field workers in and it turns
out this has happened at various places
in Africa when poaching was particularly
fierce
there's looks like there's just a gene
or two that affects whether the elephant
has a tusks or not and it has the you
know the evolution it has when the
pressure is that enormous as the ability
to respond in give you a tuskless
elephant for the time that ivory is the
way that you don't live anymore so in
places where they're not killed for bush
meat anymore they're just killed for
ivory and that's the thing that that
keeps you from reproducing you can
imagine that you know even a slow
reproducing animal like an elephant will
do an evolutionary workaround what I'm
getting at is does life always find a
way
yeah I mean that's how life works right
I mean ecosystems are dynamic and
they're constantly changing and they
change in response to the species that
are there in the species that are not
there and we see how species that are
invasive considered to be invasive that
come into a particular climate from
somewhere else because they're
accidentally introduced on the bow of a
ship for with some plant cutting that
comes across that you can have a pretty
plant in your garden how these species
can get into and sometimes not take off
and other times for completely unknown
reason this completely take off and
replace native species that are there
it's it's it's impossible to predict a
hundred percent of the time what's gonna
happen in the natural world we can't
control everything but you know if the
biggest fear of trying this if the
biggest fear of genetically modifying
elephants that they can live in North
America is that the elephant that gets
into North America is somehow going to
be weirder than an elephant in some way
that we didn't appreciate elephants that
live in Africa I would rather Lee hat
rather have slightly weird North
American elephants than no elephants we
both met elephants and said elephants
have this really sensitive trunk and
when you first meet an asian elephant
they thing they do is they reach down
with their trunk and sniff your shoes
see where you've been lately and then
they then they basically open the
conversation but as you said with this
trunk they reach right in your soul and
take your heart these are amazingly
lovable and engage about animals and I
think that's one of the attractions a
mammoth here all right Colby coming in
from another angle says we use this kind
of thinking the engineer ourselves to
sustain the effects of climate change
do we need engineering I think we're
pretty good at engineering our
environment and changing everything
around us so that we can we can evolve
that but sure I mean this is one of the
biggest controversies about this
technology is that it can be used to
engineer here
I mean there's no reason that it
couldn't be other than ethical and
that's scary
controversial Kevin Kelly asked what
about making brand new species new
hybrids
I mean hybridization happens all the
time in nature right and you know we got
coyotes a little bit with anything
there's a coyote on the east coast now
that can take down a white-tailed deer
and hunt in packs and stuff like that
Wow so far they're leaving people alone
there you are clever but you know you're
talking about an intention versus
letting it happen I think people are
gonna be creating new kinds of pets
pretty soon
don't you I think that was one of the
first things you asked me was whether or
not we could use the technology to make
a cat with wings or something that was a
cat that would do what you told it that
would you know that is completely
impossible but then it's not it's
interesting because one of the things
and you know this was the whole
sociobiology debate that no wilson set
off a couple of decades ago is you know
how much behavior is genetic what's your
thought on that how much behaviors
genetic I think we don't know I think
that and you know what's what's
fascinating to me along the lines of how
much we don't know is the the new work
that's being done on them on the
microbiome on the stuff that lives in
our gut and showing that how a lot of
behavior is actually influenced by the
stuff that's in happening our intestines
rather than by our own DNA or the
environment that we live in I think
there's a big unknown out there and
presumably one will start with a
microbiome of the sort of surrogate
parents and then go from there all right
yeah it's really hard to know how one
might create the microbe the ancient
microbiome we do have gut contents from
mammoths and other species that have
been mummified in the frozen soil but
it's really hard to know what microbes
you get out of that gut that are
from the gut versus from the the soil
that's nearby we've done a couple of
experiments where we've taken DNA from
the gut and then also from soil next to
where the mummies were found and we find
very similar microbial communities but
we don't know if that's because this
stuff from the gut gets into the soil or
because stuff from the soil gets into
the gut that's a to be discovered to be
discovered a guy watching the live
stream named sam says what should we be
doing now to help future generations we
call species that are endangered today
if they should go extinct well I think
one of the most powerful projects that's
going on right now is the project that
Oliver Ryder at the San Diego Zoo has
been in charge of for a while the the
the frozen zoo where he's been
collecting tissue samples or other
materials from everything as much as he
can get his hands on things that are
endangered and things that are not
endangered and sampling lots of
different diversity from things and
preserving that stuff in a very in
frozen liquid nitrogen in San Diego Zoo
so that when this technology does become
available that the resources that we
might need to be able to engineer
diversity into populations will exist in
fact of he 30 years ago cryopreserved a
couple of black footed ferrets that were
not part of the seven founders that made
the several thousand firs that now exist
badly and bred and we are in the process
of working with him to see if we can
clone those two specimens back into
living ferrets because Crabbe reserved
tissue which is the answer to that
question is basically viable cells with
viable DNA right and I have seen the
cell line from those ferrets swinging
around in a petri dish going you know
it's alive and we can clone those
creatures and hopefully get back to nine
founders at least and that's a start
and also continue to care about and
protect habitats and species that are
alive today this is not a band-aid for
the problem that work going through this
is not a replacement for the energy that
we should be using to conserve and
preserve things - absolutely
Pierre Schwartz has are the plants worth
restoring and would be easier or harder
well that's a good question plants are
maybe both easier and harder you know
there's a really fascinating project
right now with the American chestnut
where it's not actually completely dead
because the shoots will grow and survive
until they get to be a certain diameter
and thickness and then the fungus
attacks the tree and it can't actually
grow past a certain age but there's a
group that's been working on using
genetic engineering and genetic
modification to come up with a genetic
cure to the disease that's killing them
and I think this is probably the most
likely to succeed the extinction project
that's out there right now if the
extinction is the right term because
it's not actually dead yet there are
seeds that from the Siberian permafrost
that Russian science has claimed they've
been able to actually generate because
the seeds themselves were not dead yeah
and were actually brought back to life
out of the frozen soil and just grew so
there's a benefits to working with
plants they also have very big very
complicated genomes so if we have to
sequence the genomes of plants sometimes
they might have you know many many times
greater number of nucleotides in their
genomes than a than an animal would so
actually identifying the genes that
might be responsible for making a plant
look or act in some way might be harder
in some cases than with an animal so
about invertebrates there's a group here
well there's a publication called the
Xerxes society and its name for the
Xerxes blue which is a butterfly
butterfly in San Francisco the one
extinct
not long ago used to live out in the
dunes and there's lots of specimens here
at the Cal Academy and so on about
bringing back an invertebrate like this
works these blue butterfly I don't I
don't know what the challenge is to
bring back an invertebrate would be at
this point it's not something that I
think has been considered very much in
the literature and it's something that I
can say with a little bit of
embarrassment I haven't thought of
either really thought through the
technical hurdles that would be
associated with that from an ethical
perspective it might be something we
should focus on maybe something like a
butterfly would be easier to bring back
from an ethical perspective
and would be just as magnificent and
awe-inspiring and encouraging for people
to see something like that brought back
so hey maybe we should think about that
for the next project okay how's the
passenger pigeon going you guys have
been the sequencing like mad your
husband runs dovetail which is this
brand-new generation of sequencing that
gets long reads and it's going to change
the whole sequencing industry you've
done the band-tailed pigeons in the
passenger pigeon what's the news from
that department well we have four there
are now four high coverage very good
quality passenger pigeon genome
sequences and we have a couple of
band-tailed pigeons and we've just been
continually surprised by what we see
there are two different types of DNA in
every cell there's the nuclear genome
that's the stuff that makes you look and
act the way you do if you're a passenger
pigeon or person and then there's the
mitochondrial genome which is a it lives
it's a mitochondria ISM is an organelle
inside cells that has its own genome
it's thought to have been absorbed at
some point by some early form of life
and a symbiotic relationship with cells
and now all of us have them and they're
only inherited through your mom so
there's no recombination it's got a very
simple evolutionary history well one of
the most surprising things we've seen
with passenger pigeons is that that
mitochondrial DNA suggests that their
population was very small or very
recently expanding and that they went
through a very recent population
bottleneck like which in the last 50,000
years or so small mean I mean it got to
be 5 billion or so yes it doesn't make
any sense at all given the census
population size but the nuclear genome
shows a lot of diversity a surprising
amount of diversity and we're still in
the middle of trying to tease apart
these differences why can we get such
conflicting results from within the same
cells and perhaps the reason is that
this bird was going through these
oscillations big populations followed by
small populations but what's most
interesting about the mitochondrial
result anyway is that the expansion
which must have happened to get it to
billions of individuals by the time
Europeans first arrived
must have been happening from before and
during the peak of the last ice age so
the bird must have been really able to
use whatever resources were available to
it including like the deciduous forests
as well as you know pine alpine forests
because there weren't widespread
deciduous forests during the peak of the
last ice age and yet there must have
been a large number of birds because you
can't go from none to billions in any
time that's shorter than since the last
ice age it's just not possible
well you guys are gonna publish all of
this sometimes eventually as soon as we
figure out what's going on I'm probably
entirely wrong about everything I just
said check back next week this is what
is so fun about these projects is
cutting edge technology in terms of the
tools that are being used and it's kind
of edge science in terms of what the
tools are discovering at each stage of
these various processes you know what
was actually the case of what they're
discovering in the ancient DNA then
they're looking at you know trying to
resurrect a sense of what the ecology
the bird was back then this information
and plays against well how resourceful a
bird was it under a time when it had a
completely different for us to live in
and so on and so forth given that kid it
can eat everything then we probably
really want it back so we can eat
everything mm-hmm so basically we I
think this is living proof that science
finds away and life finds away thank you
for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you